hello and happy new year welcome to
blender as a video editor tutorial we're
going to go over all the basics that you
need to know to start editing your
videos
with blender so first of all what you
want to do is get blender and you can
get blender for free for any os
at blender.org
so go here
go to download
and get the latest blender you should
see blender 3.0
if you're in the future maybe there's a
later later version but a lot of this
stuff should still
work it's not a huge file 203 megabytes
is pretty small for a video editor these
days once you have it installed you
should just have it
so i'm not going to walk through the
whole install process but
that's essentially where we're picking
up
now
all right so once you have blender go
ahead and open it
and you should get a nice blender
layout thing
this is going to start with your
defaults you can save the defaults later
you're going to see some stuff down here
like new file these are all just
help
things and if you really like blender
you can donate to the development fund
if you really like my videos you can
donate to me with uh
the join button here on youtube so
instead of hiring a video editor you can
learn it from me and just give me three
dollars instead of paying hundreds to a
video editor you can also support me on
patreon and if you want source code to
my private stuff join the source level i
appreciate you guys
and also don't forget to like hit
subscribe and hit the bell to be
notified of new stuff now that that's
out of the way let's dive into it
you can just click anywhere in the scene
and this little helper thing will pop
will go away you can bring it back up
anytime by going to
the top left this blender icon it's kind
of hard to see splash screen and there
it is
all right but we're going to focus on
video editing blender can do a ton of
stuff it can model it can animate we're
not going to worry about that if you're
new to it and want to learn more there
are lots of other tutorials out there
and also let me know what you would like
to see
so we're just going to go straight to
video editing there's a couple different
ways to do this and i'm just going to
cover the one i usually use so you see
all these tabs at the top they're kind
of workflow setups you can customize
these window layouts it's just a blender
thing and all these are just different
customized layouts and viewports and
stuff so one of them you got to hit this
plus button
is video editing and there's rendering
and video editing we're going to go to
actual video editing here
and it takes us to this screen now this
is the important screen you want to go
to if you only use blender for video
editing you can once you have your
basics set up you can go to file
and
defaults save startup file so you can
default it to one of whatever of these
you want you don't have to have the
default cube
now let's talk about these different
sections here because this is kind of
important
top left this is a file area you can see
your path on your drive so keep in mind
that this is just a default layout if
you don't like any of this stuff you can
click
up in the top left and change it to
something else and if you want to make
more you can click on the top right of
any of these so you pull to the right
from an edge
there we go we want to collapse these
all in it looks like if you drag into
another one from
one you can collapse them in
it's kind of a little wonky takes a
little bit used to
let's put this back to file browser a
little bit of a different layout this
time that's fine though
you can change that with view
if you want
and these buttons so a lot of little
stuff like that but okay we don't want
to get stuck on that too much and over
here we have your actual video editing
viewport you can see it's set to this
little
uh
movie looking thing and we got preview
right here let's just leave that preview
and we have some buttons here we're not
going to worry about too much because i
don't think we're going to use those
now over on the right we have properties
properties is super important
this has a bunch of tabs over here for
different things about your scene and
your layout and all that and we don't
really need to mess with any of these a
lot of these are for material and 3d
scenes and stuff the only one we really
want is
this one here and it's called output
properties now we need to change this
because when we
export our video or render our video
it's going to do in a certain way and
that's determined by how you set these
output properties i'm going to just show
you how i like to do it and you can
change as needed so mine are typically
for a 1080
youtube video so the resolution here
says 1920 by 1080. we're going to leave
that aspect ratio one by one we're going
to leave that
for under region we're just going to
leave all these don't change the frame
rate i'll talk about frame rate here
when we're importing videos because it
is important
as well
so we're going to skip over all these
and go all the way down to where it says
output now by default your output
directory is just slash temp
you can change this
by clicking this
little uh folder on the right
and picking your your the volume your
drive and your path i like to save it to
one of my external drives called l mass
and then rendered so i'm just going to
click those and hit accept hit accept
now you can see it has that here so when
we render that's where everything's
going to go
still really a lot more important stuff
here so let's pay close attention
file format it's defaulted to png so
when you render it's going to give you a
whole bunch of pngs which might be what
you want depending on what you're doing
you got to change this to ffmpeg
that's the one that seems to be
well even says in the tooltip here the
most versatile way to output video files
so ffmpeg
is very nice stick with rb rgb unless
you want black and white that's up to
you and now encoding this is actually
really important too so we want to
expand this little encoding tab
and make sure we get a proper
setup here
audio if you have audio along with your
video you have to change this codec it
defaults to no
so when you render with blender
if you don't change all this stuff
you're going to get a bunch of pngs into
that temp folder with no audio so yeah
you got to change this
to aac seems to be very good
so we're going to stick with aac
we're going to leave all this stuff the
same
and that should be all we need to do
here you can mess with the quality a
little bit if you the higher you go the
bigger your file but it'll be a little
bit more quality
but
the higher quality you get the
exponentially larger your video file
gets so usually medium quality is just
fine unless you want the finest most
highest quality
and that should be it for
the settings here
all right now let's look at the bottom
here we're going to see a few more
sections that are important we see the
sequencer
and this is set to sequencer by
this stuff here as you can see it's the
same video tab but this one's sequencer
as where this one is preview you can
also have just one and do sequencer and
preview and have it split it
so however you want to do that's fine
we're going to leave it how it was so
the sequencer is where you put
your video files
and you can see a timeline at the top
so it has frames you can see if you look
at this closely you'll see it has
seconds on the first you know zero zero
there and the second part is how many
frames because right now we're set to 24
frames per second
so it's going to flip through 24 you see
this little plus 11 we're on 11th frame
and so on once we get to the 24th it
starts over
so you can see we have nice little frame
sections here every second
uh now i wanted to talk about the frame
rate in your videos because this this is
where a lot of people get hosed
we'll say
so if your frame rate doesn't match the
video file that you're bringing in
your audio is going to be shorter or
longer and your video is going to seem
it's just not going to render right you
need to get
this frame rate matched with your video
file that way everything lines up nicely
[Music]
so let's go get a file let's just go uh
up and up again up again and up again
or to the c drive well we ultimately
want to go to our e drive so we're just
going to type it in here
because that's where i store a lot of my
videos
your you just need to go to where you
store your videos
now if you don't want to mess with this
at all i'm just going to leave a little
caveat right in here what you can do is
you can just open up your windows file
browser and just go to it manually and
drag it in so you can drag it in from
your file explorer
rather than using this it's the whole
point either way it's fine e
look for my recording drive
looks like it's over here
i have a layout kind of strange
and there we go there's all the files
uh you can click on this one for display
mode and get a little preview of them
but all right at this point we just need
to pick one so let's grab this magic the
gathering one i don't know what this is
and you just draw and drag it in here
boom
and now what happens is your frame rate
auto adjusts to the very first video you
bring in as you can see just by me
dragging this in here it switched to 60.
now this is important so listen closely
because a lot of people get messed up on
this
all your videos need to have the same
frame rate blender does not do well with
multiple different frame rates it
doesn't automatically
adjust videos you need to do that on
your own there are ways to do this there
are tools
one of my favorite is handbrake and
brake allows you to convert video files
allows you to change frame rates and
stuff like that it's a free tool that's
just one way of doing it there are some
other tools but handbrake is a nice easy
freeway that allows you to to get your
frame rates matched up if they don't
match up if they're already all the same
it's fine you don't need to worry about
it
so it's only when you're mixing and
matching videos that you need to get
them all into the same frame rate
okay so we got our video here it's doing
this you saw that here you can see
there's something going on here blender
is executing something get out of the
way you can see it down here at the
bottom too it says building proxies you
used to have to manually build proxies
and now proxies build automatically when
you drag a video in now what this is is
just like little temporary files that
help you navigate along this timeline
faster because when proxies are built
it basically has them all saved all
these frames saved and ready in a
smaller format so that it can flip
through your video quicker otherwise
you're going to get a lot of a lot more
stuttering without the proxies if you
don't want the proxies maybe you're
already fast enough or anything you can
just hit this x and stop the job
all right in our case we're going to go
ahead and stop the job
because i don't particularly want
those right now this is just the demo
you can see the video is not lined up to
the start so now we're going to get into
how to edit and cut videos and just do
some some basic tweaking to your videos
here
and this is going to get a little bit
detailed i'm actually going to hide this
uh file thing for now
we might bring in more files later
but we'll do it via our operating system
uh file explorer anyway
so that's gonna be fine so this
sequencer you if it's too small like if
you can you know this is a really long
file but how do you keep going over
well you got to drag this bottom thing
if you click these little dots it
expands out makes it wider
all right so let's stretch this to see
our actual whole video
and then you can move it around just by
dragging somewhere else but these little
dots on the edge
zoom you in and out
you can do that with mouse wheel too but
if you're on like a laptop without a
mouse where you gotta do these dots and
you can do the same thing for the
vertical space too and you can see what
track you're on one two etc now we see
two files
it looks like two files it's only one
and it's because one of these is a video
and one of these is the audio that goes
with the video so if you want you can
like
delete the audio and i did that by
clicking it and then pressing the delete
key on my keyboard so you can just wipe
out a part of the video if you don't
want it the audio is terrible you can
just delete it no big deal we want to
cut and do a little rendering
[Music]
now as
by default
the render area is only like a few
seconds it's this small gray area you
see right there
if we hit render right now that's what
it would render just this little section
so we want to do a few things first of
all
since we kind of want to make this a
sample i'm going to zoom away and bear
with me a second all right
so we want to like line it up to the
beginning right so you can just double
you can click and drag and do this box
select to get both of them you can also
use shift and where control
control click selects the matching pair
shift lets you individually select stuff
so once you have stuff selected you can
just click and drag it and we can line
this up you can see it says the frame
right there
that it's starting at so we just want to
start this at like frame one or zero
one's fine
so now our video will actually start at
the first frame
and uh
it's only gonna go
for
four seconds it looks like so after like
four and a half seconds
or so
it uh it stops the video and that's all
we get so to change this end time you
got to change the start and end down
here and you can see your current frame
right there
so
you go to where you want it to stop
basically you don't need to necessarily
do this right away but at some point
before you render you got to change this
because this is the render section this
is about a 40
minute long video so
if we go to the very last frame we see
that it's like
147 000 it's a lot of frames 60 per
second
so you can grab this number and put it
on the end and boom our render area
extends and now it would render the
whole area i haven't done any cuts or
edits or anything so this is still like
the same video file as before just as a
quick example because i get this one a
lot too
when you want to render you change this
render area to the desired area yeah you
might want the full thing at the end but
at some point you might say hey i just
want to render this little section or
something else so you change your start
frame to where you want change your end
frame to where you want and now you can
render just that section so how do you
render make sure you have these outputs
set up how you want
get that area selected how you want it
with the start to end and then go up
here to render
render animation or press ctrl f12
and this will start
rendering i'm going to hit it i'm going
to cancel i'm not going to do the whole
thing but i'm just going to hit it for
example
render
it brings up this little
uh result thing where it's going to show
you how it's going
but if you go to where it's saved or
where you chose the output for me it was
rendered you'll see it
right there with your specifics now
don't mess with this file when you
probably actually just want to let your
computer do its thing walk away
but there you go
[Music]
[Music]
you